the guns will start in 30 seconds to
fire
this death gun salute in marking a life
of service to the queen by her consort
and these will be echoed at six other
locations
and also on board two ships at sea
and in gibraltar
it has just gone noon you're watching
sky news live coverage of the death gun
salute
to mark the duke of edinburgh who died
yesterday
and returning to edinburgh castle where
there is now
time for the gun which has just fired to
be reloaded
and also time to reflect again on how
the duke of edinburgh had carried the
name of this city
the capital of scotland in his life
all around the world and for
him therefore this firing of the gun
has its own significance as the next gun
is fired
we now go across the country to london
where the simultaneous second shot has
been fired by the honorable artillery
company
the oldest regiment in the british army
the tower of london
where the crown jewels of the united
kingdom are stored
and to which the duke came on a number
of occasions not least
when he was appointed by the queen to be
the chairman
of the coronation committee just after
she came to the throne and organized
the coronation in 1953. it is the great
citadel
of england and it is the well-known
guarding point at the entrance of london
where the prince
did so much of his service to the queen
working from palace
and at cardiff castle too preparing for
this gun salute
you'll see the firing and then the
discharge
of the shell case they are of course
blank firing
today but these guns new battle and
they were guns that were in operation
and service in
some of the battlefields that were being
fought hard over
when the duke of edinburgh as a young
officer in the royal navy
was along with the army and the royal
air force across all the allies
fighting against the axis powers of
tyranny in the second world war add to
fire
evidence of the queen when she is in
northern ireland of course throughout
the queen's reign
the struggles for
security and peace within a nation that
has a history of discord
has been very much a part of the queen's
reign and we remember when
the duke of edinburgh accompanied the
queen to go to
ireland on that historic state visit
and also what a great deal it had meant
to him
to see peace returned there after the
struggles
of that time particularly with the loss
of his uncle
lord mountbatten but to devenport and
the royal navy
are firing their guns also
in salute at davenport the historic and
largest
of the naval bases of europe
number one gun fire
wearing the anti-flash that is always
worn on board ship particularly when
guns firing in battle
battles that prince philip as i say
remembered very much
seeing start in italy at the beginning
of his service in the second world war
and suddenly realizing as he said and
then they all started firing back and
you suddenly realized
that this was real war he was also out
in japan
at the time that the piece was finally
assigned
at the end of hostilities in 1945.
we now get willage with its ancient
history as
a scene of the revittling of ships
nearby at detford
and royal horse artillery
are preparing to fire their guns the
king's troop royal horse artillery
the guns here are firing in front of the
largest frontage of
any building of the georgian period 1
000
feet long massive building with the guns
laid out in front of the center of that
building where the old officer's mess
and
duke of edinburgh frequently went as a
guest there
because his reach into the armed forces
was so considerable
as a field marshal for longer than
anyone else had ever been
in
going to portsmouth next and at
portsmouth where so many occasions
a young naval officer prince philip
would have set out to see
to play his part in the battles and
again the anti-flash will remind us
of what warfare is like in a ship
[Music]
and perhaps one of the most dangerously
protected areas
during the second world war was in
gibraltar where the great guns
were protecting the entrance to the
mediterranean and through which
their submarine nets the prince
saw that preparation as the guns fired
there too
enormous amount of smoke and the
well gibraltar regiment will after all
had to defend the rock through some very
difficult times in history
going way back to the very start of its
part of british ownership
back to edinburgh castle and the seat of
the dukedom of edinburgh
and the gun is about to be fired
[Applause]
[Music]
and it's a beautiful day in edinburgh
too with
the wonderful views from the castle i'm
very proud to be its governor at the
moment
and i'm very proud too of the excellence
of the royal regiment of artillery in
delivering this salute to the duke of
edinburgh
and what a day and the duke who loved
scotland he was educated at gordenstein
he was up at balmoral with the royal
family frequently and each year
the queen and he came up for royal week
to mark the duties and particularly
opening the scottish parliament
when that moment came